I'm on duty
welcome to dirty Rd chapter 23 23 and if
you didn't see last episode we're not in
read that anymore it's now fall out it's
fall out we went through some kind of oh
yeah through some kind of wormhole space
time continuum got breakage and we so
old man that had exploited those pistols
very good and you've made some changes
you got you added some mods to make him
even more
well no mods what I did some console
commands and messed with the game a
little bit so we could make it a little
more Western because people were saying
oh you guys should have done new vegas
the reason we didn't do new vegas is
because we wanted already as a kid yeah
now that beautiful intro being born but
now we've got a six-shooter a 44 magnum
I guess Hayley and a duster and a cowboy
hat perfect so a sheriff yeah things so
so what are we doing in this episode
we're gonna blow this city up Elias we
go outside let him calm down a little
bit so the reason the reason the reason
we ready to kill him is because now that
I have his duster I'm the sheriff he's
not the sheriff Oh sheriff sheriff the
first love is to blow up my seat I think
they calm down I don't know what that
nope they all seem pretty riled up still
just kill him so there's someone here
you don't want to kill their son I need
to talk to you but he's into buildings
he's not gonna he's a cat so he's not
he's not
of type yes so I used the console
command to get a 44 Magnum so I was like
that sort of all that's perfect for
Artie
however he's avoiding people like for
reference so I did I got a couple guns
I got a reservist rifle damage 27th
that's pretty good damage sawed-off
shotgun 34 pretty good damage here's the
32 pistol he had it was three damage 44
Magnum is 6030 damage what why and look
it's like broke it's like pip OS air it
doesn't know what that is
talk about Opie maybe there's something
maybe there's like some secret gun and
follow that I'm forgetting about cuz I
haven't played three and forever but
yeah tight man I've been to Megaton so
long what's your plan dude you got a
knife look out I got put your knife this
guy
I'm just when I at all but giving up oh
my dear boy oh man I'm very happy to
make your acquaintance
make it as you wish I'm looking to
employ an individual with no ties to
Megaton no interest in its future
Megaton is obsolete the last vestige of
a cobbled desperate past it needs to go
away very you are going to see that it
does I have in my possession a fusion
pulse charge once rigged to the bomb it
will be detonated by you at a secure
location
they're disrespectful of your
conversation let you finish
oh you're gone I'm out of here that gun
is 200 feet oh you didn't make it I got
shotgun
gladiator guns to open this bar what I
also overheard your whole conversation
self we're gonna leave that was a so
it's just terrifying how quickly of
course I'm fine
I got Springs on my feet welcome weary
traveler you look like a traveller in
need of relaxation and the finest of
chemical well wander no more my good
friend for I am doc Hoff procurer of the
finest of medical conditions now how may
I help you
Yusei you tell me what you need
[Laughter]
SiC that nice doing business with you
[Music]
Turing turning around seeing about you
skipping shooting how are you
oh that death claw ooh and some power
armor we kind of need some power armor
huh where you going I forgot the cars
explode in this game hmm Artie's got a
cannon let's go see good yeah hell yeah
that's the thing we can do we can do
that now
that's client yeah let's take a death
client I think someone's coming hope you
got a room for me please help me I'm
dying I was a critical strike on Willy
what did you just draw
enjoy kicking the [ __ ] out of you well
then do it
alright let me in right away
what hello Oh Oh No
yeah let them both watch and then throw
their bodies off it was fast no delay
wait are you saying 7 my ears hurt
oh he arranged it after I've God all
right well let's see that explosion one
more time yeah I'm down that's pretty
cool explosion dang it let's mess that
up that's ok this building is mine now
where's that guard yes yup I like it
better now I don't want that robot all
right I don't like that metal looking
robot
I'm on duty oh where you want to run
good business be smart strong be fair
that's up there I'm on duty
yes it's disdain
you are alive a lot of stimpaks though
knock-knock Lucky's hi I'm dirty Artie
ha ha ha maybe it'd be best for me to
use a sniper yeah normal you know what I
want oh there it is that's it right yeah
Pig so you asked do you like my hat
watch me fall out of the sky though oh
whoa this is this is perfect
what's going on here this is exactly how
it happened
we got a load and do new instances
something oh my god oh the hell yeah
there's that sick ass gun we've already
broken it hey kid you're not gonna talk
he's probably weirded out
this is like some potato mode stuff yeah
it really is that was a bad idea on your
guys so we state your business in Rivet
City
oh I'm just wandering around freaking em
out of here
all right you're free to roam around so
long as you don't do anything stupid
like try to slit my throat when I'm
sleeping all right maybe you should
reload okay all right we're good sick
wow that loaded real quick what say your
shopping cart I mean psych welcome to
Gary's galley can I take your order
look at me turn around it's noisy dark
and smelly but we're safe here I'm death
look this is a restricted area it's you
My heavens you look so much like him
okay you're James's son aren't you
I am what are you doing here Oh back to
running
[Laughter]
good luck haha okay yeah I think it's
safe to say how we can kill everyone now
we built rivets in it what's there we go
stop a god
I need to get some health what happened
I don't know twitching the dismembered
in this game is so funny it's so [ __ ]
funny
alright my bike
alright it's been good ziyal maybe some
trouble someone might threaten the
integrity of your base oh no you just
get into position what are we doing
we're I guess there's a level of
confusion I would have I got shot in the
back where and now it's time for show us
your arty where you guys send in your
own interpretations and creations of
dirty arty first up we have a mod or
doozy dragon I picked this one because
why did you why did you pick it well one
law do you see in this image lots about
lots of bodies but I definitely chuckle
that it wasn't me about 800 rounds were
used that's a lot already would have
been dead before then it's true very
nice thank you for submitting that this
one's epic feature creature he sent in a
couple before sent this one in it's got
a nice cinematic look to it I think he
said this was uh if dirty already had a
solo album this would be the cover art
for it and I would agree I don't
someone called me stupid says Jackson
Brennan that's pretty good pile of
bodies such this one's really cool
sketches come in
I love this one I love how full that
beard looks it looks way more
well-groomed than it should be but it
looks very good totally the Hat and all
and I love the nose I like it almost
looks like punched in it's very good
very awesome thank you made Artie this
one was from a while ago and I was
scrolling through and found it and we
missed it but it is so cool-looking it's
so good this is from Max Yun for three I
don't know string of numbers but that's
awesome yeah that is that is some talent
right there my god yeah awesome awesome
drawing this was from mr. pills he sent
in a bunch of cool photos I picked this
one though just cuz I like the guy
laying down on top of the yeah of the
horse there's nothing like shot off yeah
yeah but definitely check check out his
Twitter because he had a lot of cool
photos as well but this is the one that
I picked cuz mr. pills looks pretty cool
I thought this one was funny just cuz
more I feel like we get so many pictures
of a pig already just hiding behind
somewhere and looking really awkward and
scary in a way just as one does giddy up
boy giant alligator freaking I forget
how big that legendary Gators oh my god
dinosaur there's my son of ander son of
ander I think he sent this another one
where people find these naked dudes
tagging bag them badass
state class yeah he also had a bunch of
cool photos or this person also had a
bunch of cool photos but I took that one
because I thought it looked pretty cool
yeah he's also the horses that give me a
D this is Cal cam is I think yeah that's
so sick and then wow we have this one
being serious
vote for me which I would never vote for
dirty Artie but I like that artwork I
love it I think we all can agree the
beans are good vote for me
I promised 10,000 percent more beans
vote for me and I will supply you all
with unlimited bean
I'll do it I'll do it well thank you
guys so much for sending those in we
will see y'all next week
take care
[Music]